Hi there, I'm Tucker Balch.
I'm a professor at Georgia Tech and
I'm the instructor for this course.
>> Hi, I'm Devpriya Dave,
a graduate student at Georgia Tech.
You can call me Dev.
>> My original research was about
machine learning for robotics,
but in 2007 I became interested in using
these same algorithms for investing.
Since that time I've shifted my
research and teaching towards finance.
I also cofounded a financial technology
company called Lucena Research.
>> I'm a graduate student who's
been working with Professor to
built up predictive system for
stock market.
I'm also working on the software
to support this course.
>> You're going to see a lot
of Dev in this course.
She makes a lot of things
happen behind the scenes.
Now Dev,
I'm thinking about buying Apple stock.
Do you think I should do it?
>> Mm, well,
it depends on a lot of factors.
What are the other stocks
in your portfolio?
What do you think will
predict stock prices?
Also, how much risk do you
think you can take it on?
>> So those are all good questions,
and Dev is exactly right.
We need to consider all of those
things before we make an investment.
Now in this course we're going
to cover a lot of these issues.
We're going to show you how information
influences the movement of a stock
price, how to build software to analyze
and visualize these relationships, and
details about how
the stock exchanges work.
Finally, in the last section
of this course we're going to
show you how to build
machine learning algorithms
that you can use to build
real trading strategies.
Now let's get started.
>> Let's do it.